President Trump and his Republican
allies are fighting the Democrats push
toward impeachment by targeting the
whistleblower in his case the president
tweeted this last night I deserved to
meet my accuser
he says the whistleblowers information
claiming mr. Trump as you cane Ukraine's
President to investigate Democratic
rival Joe Biden is largely incorrect on
60 minutes last night House Intelligence
Chairman Adam Schiff told Scott Pelley
that his committee will hear from the
whistleblower very soon Democrats may
deliver subpoenas to the president's
lawyers as early as today the latest CBS
News poll finds 55% of Americans approve
of the impeachment inquiry but 58% say
the president doesn't deserve to be
impeached or it's too early to say Nancy
Cordes is on Capitol Hill Nancy what are
the next steps in this investigation in
the house good morning well they've got
multiple depositions scheduled over the
next couple of weeks they have
subpoenaed documents from the Secretary
of State that they're expecting to get
by the end of this week and Democratic
leaders say there could be more
subpoenas and hearing scheduled even
though technically Congress is at the
start of a two-week break we could not
ignore what the President did he gave us
no choice in an interview with Scott
Pelley on 60 minutes House Speaker Nancy
Pelosi said she spoke to President Trump
about his now infamous call with the
president of Ukraine he told you about
the phone call he told me it was perfect
there was nothing in the call but I knew
what was in the call I mean it was in
the public domain he didn't even know
that it was wrong you know who saying it
was perfect there was nothing wrong I
know it is wrong a summary of the call
released by the White House shows the
president asked his Ukrainian
counterpart to look into an unproven
theory about a Democratic National
Committee computer server and into
unsubstantiated corruption claims about
former Vice President Joe Biden and his
son an Intelligence Committee
whistleblower wrote in a memo that White
House officials were deeply disturbed
your committee already has an agreement
with the whistleblower that he will
testify we have agreement that he or she
will testify yes
Intelligence Committee Chairman Adam
Schiff said his committee will subpoena
information from the president's
personal lawyer Rudy Giuliani the
whistleblowers complaint alleges
Giuliani repeatedly urged Ukrainian
officials to investigate Biden
we're gonna need evidence from Rudy
Giuliani and it's our intention as soon
as first thing next week to subpoena him
for documents and there may very well
come a time where we want to hear from
him directly
Giuliani denies any wrongdoing and only
one house Republican Nevada's mark
Amodei has announced support for the
oversight process that comes with an
impeachment inquiry when I read the
transcript I see two leaders having
admiration not intimidation House
Minority Leader Kevin McCarthy insisted
there was no impeachable behavior in
that phone call you say the president
has done nothing wrong I take that to
mean that you find it appropriate that
the president asked mr. szalinski for an
investigation of his Democratic rivals
question before the House of
Representatives is to impeach the
president based upon a phone call that
the speaker never even heard
lawyers for the whistleblower dispute
chairmanships claim that an agreement
has been reached for the whistleblower
to testify they say that details are
still being worked out and that no date
or time has been set yet Toni Nancy
thank you